[Music]
breaking news alert
this just into our newsroom nhp is
reporting a deadly crash on blue diamond
near pahrump troopers say one child was
killed in the crash that involved two
cars we're told a family of eight was
traveling northbound on blue diamond
when this happened the northbound lanes
are closed at this time this is a
developing story we'll of course bring
you more updates as we get them on air
and online
meantime a deadly night on our valley
roadways as officials continue to urge
caution during the labor day weekend we
thank you for joining us tonight at six
o'clock i'm sasha loftis three deadly
crashes happen saturday night in just
the span of five hours orco mana joins
us live tonight with the details and
what traffic safety advocates are saying
orco
sasha the office of traffic safety here
in nevada has been trying to encourage
drivers and pedestrians to be as safe as
possible especially during this holiday
weekend but last night we saw the 88th
89th and 90th traffic related death in
the las vegas area in metro's
jurisdiction this year around 8 45 last
night police say a car hit a pedestrian
near desert inn and mccloud
and that crash they believe impairment
was not suspected they say the man was
walking
crossing the street outside a marked
crosswalk when the driver hit him and a
couple hours earlier around 6 15 police
say a driver lost control near south
durango and bedura the car hit a street
lamp post and overturned the driver died
an impairment is suspected in that case
and just before 4 yesterday afternoon a
motorcyclist died after a collision with
the fedex truck near lake mead in
wynwood traffic safety officials tell me
they're frustrated but committed to
keeping everyone safe
as we you know continue with sunday and
monday
it's important that people understand
through education and enforcement we
intend to reach our goal of zero
fatalities every single day we are
stepping up enforcement today the rest
of today and tomorrow
to try to be able to achieve that goal
now while only one of three crashes
saturday are suspected to involve
impairment the nevada office of traffic
safety tells me impaired driving is
still a major concern especially for a
holiday weekend that's why the las vegas
coalition for zero fatalities is
offering 15 thousand dollars in free
lift ride credits for new and existing
users this labor day weekend you can get
ten dollars off one lift ride with the
code ridesmart ldw and that
option that code is available now 3 6
a.m tomorrow reporting live in las vegas
orca mana 8 news now